is if we needed any more confirmation
that Madison cawthorne being kicked out
of the House of Representatives after
just one term is a very very good thing
I'm going to present to you today
exhibit number 150 of why cawthorne
using his final speaking opportunity on
the floor of the house to rail against
and I quote here
soft metrosexuals
take a look at this clip this is a guy
who seems obsessed with gender stuff and
even cultural issues that aren't big
issues now I think it's been 12 years
since I heard the term metrosexual abuse
here is Madison cawthorne delivering
this final principled and defiant speech
on the floor of the House of
Representatives our young man are taught
that weakness and strength that delicacy
is desirable and that being a soft
metrosexual is more valuable than
training the Mind Body and Soul
social media has weakened us siphoning
our men of their will to fight to rise
in a noble manner Square their jaws and
charge once more into the breach of life
to defend what they love
so on this precipice of disaster I asked
the young men of this nation a question
will you sit behind a screen while the
story tales of your forefathers become
myth or will you stand Resolute against
the dying light of America's Golden Age
We reclaim your masculinity will you
become a man to be feared to be
respected to be looked up to or you let
this nation's Next Generation be its
final generation that line about will
you become a man to be feared
you know
call me crazy
but I respect people
who Garner respect not who make others
afraid and in fact often those who make
others afraid
are quite cowardly people when it really
comes down to it and this is really you
know it's easy to say oh it's Madison
cawthorne with another one of his wacky
rants on his way out don't let the door
hit you as you as you exit sort of thing
but he brings up an idea or a concept
that is becoming increasingly common
among the right which is that fear is
they just love fear in every sense they
they see those who are feared as
powerful and to be respected they use
fear-based politics and fear-mongering
to get people to vote from for them oh
the you've got to be afraid of the
violent immigrants that are coming in
and you've got to be afraid of the crazy
Communists that have taken over Congress
and of course none of these things are
true
um fear is a big part of their politics
and Madison cawthorne just explaining an
additional way in which that's the case
now as far as the metrosexual stuff I
don't know that I've heard anyone
complain about metrosexual since 2008
like yeah very very early in 2008 I
would even say and for people who maybe
don't remember or never knew what that
term meant metrosexual referred to a
young often Urban
heterosexual male
often with left-leaning political views
who's interested in fashion and has what
might be considered a refined sense of
taste and it was a way of criticizing
heterosexuals who you can't just say oh
they're gay by saying this is a brand of
heterosexuality that is sort of less
manly and less masculine again I haven't
heard metrosexual as a term used in a
very very long time but we clearly know
what is on Madison cawthorne's mind good
habits have to be sustainable in order
to become habits it has to be something
you'll actually do and when it comes to
nutrition some people have hours to plan
out every meal their exact vitamin
intake I'm not doing any of that I don't
have the time here's what's sustainable
for me I start my day with just a single
scoop of ag-1 from athletic greens it
gives me the entire day's worth of the
75 high quality vitamins minerals and
probiotics I want from whole food
sources it's just simple it's just one
scoop of ag1 I get all the nutrients I
want I don't have to do any math use my
protractor my TI-83 or take a bunch of
different capsules and pills it's not
some kind of wacky supplement making a
bunch of crazy claims you know I would
not promote something like that ag1 is
just a simple product it does what it
says it does it gives you the daily
nutrients and vitamins you likely want
vitamin A C E magnesium zinc potassium
in one simple scoop you keep your body
nourished you'll also get a free year
supply of vitamin D which I take in the
winter plus five free travel packs at
athleticgreens.com Pacman the link is
down below